the white sturgeon of the upper Columbia
River is an endangered species but I
just hit the jackpot
struggling I'm with Larry he'll abandon
his team and we've caught a beautiful
adult fish the question is is it a
female oh it's big the only way to find
out is to examine the fish surgically so
while the guys set up the o.r I make
sure the fish isn't stressed it's a
beautiful fish that classic slender
sturgeon shape these big fins it's
almost like wings the fish is almost
using these things like wings to
Orient's itself into the current so
these fish feed okay with their pectoral
fins out this is flying through the
water historically sturgeon get much of
their food from the ocean they actually
do go into the saltwater the brackish
water area for feeding depending on what
the resources are fish here has no
chance to get down to the officiator has
never been to the ocean because there's
14 dams between here and the in the
Pacific yes this population had to adapt
to being cut off from that rich ocean
diet which might explain why the fish
I've seen here are smaller than I
expected the team is ready first we'll
get the basics weight length and girth
this information goes into a database
that monitors sturgeon caught on the
Columbia 125 subtracting the weight of
the stretcher that makes this fish 115
pounds
size 14 hook size 14 hook it's okay
they're checking for attack
there's a new Fishman handled it before
you need to get me out on this
so is it while you hold that right at
the tip of the snow okay red stuff I'm
gonna take it out a bit
the fourth length is 177 1.77 meter is
almost exactly six feet it's a mega fish
but that's the problem all the wild
sturgeon here are adults so so there
have it there's been no reproduction
these fish these large adult fish have
not been able to reproduce
since the dams when in the 1960s exactly
they haven't been able to reproduce
enough young to replace themselves in
the population and that means the
population of these large individuals is
declining every year getting older is
this a gene getting older and older they
can't these fish can't reproduce
eventually they can go extinct exactly
the dams on this river have interfered
with the sturgeons ability to reproduce
what I want to know is how I'm just
gonna affect the area right now
I'm hoping that this fish will give me a
clue it's a remarkably calm they are but
every once awhile they will explore ok
the skin of these fish is quite thick so
I'll make a very shallow incision to
grab on and then I can lift the body
wall away from the organs just be a
little safer so you've gone through the
skin and now you're the fish team is
called and the procedure is sterile but
we have to work fast inside the body
fabric just into the body cavity now I'm
gonna look inside with the otoscope
which is really a doctor with you to
look in your ears for instance do you
have any sense whether that's a male or
a female
I do know there's eggs inside the
otoscope this fish is likely to spawn
this year oh that's amazing I would that
answers one question for me
the sturgeon here are generating eggs if
I would not have suspect there there's
so many eggs in there I can't see more
than about a centimeter this is great
the team will now tag her with an
electronic transmitter so they can track
her during spawning to learn if and
where she deposits her eggs so this is a
sonic tag and this tag has a life of
about ten years these are long-lived
things to me and we will get a lot of
information I can see that she's still
breathing strong her heels are moving so
the tags in just suture it up
sit her up and back you look like you
know you're doing so do do humans too or
just fish obviously it's a little bit
tired now try to get a little bit of
oxygen through its gills it's just a
beautiful fish and I think she's ready
to go so I guess it's time to say
goodbye see if we can get her to swim
away Wow
there she go I got act